le château de versailles peut-il et
doit-il accueillir toutes les formes
d'art même les plus osées en 2008 les
homards ou josef kunz avait déjà fait
polémique
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est l'exposition
du japonais mur et camille qui déchaîne
les passions
pour certains on brise l'harmonie des
lieux marie bérurier laurent beaufils
l'urac amis au château de versailles
voilà à quoi ça ressemble une vraie
folie médiatique car à 47 ans murat
khémisset une grande star de l'art
contemporain
bon d'accord murakami tout le monde ne
connaît pas son travail
alors voilà à quoi ça ressemble un
univers fantasmagorique
alice au pays des merveilles version
manga et jeux vidéo
je trouve qu'il a sa place au c'est donc
la personne il a de la chance d'ailleurs
de pouvoir être exposés ici
l'art à versailles c'est toujours un
sujet sensible et sa takashi murakami le
savez parfaitement
il y a deux ans les oeuvres de
l'américain jeff koons dans les
appartement royaux avaient déclenché une
émeute et une action judiciaire
alors cette fois murat camille lui a été
prudent même si salah gas de le
reconnaître en tant qu'artiste je n'ai
pas l'habitude contrairement à ce que
l'on a l'air de croire de moi de faire
des choses provocante je ne sais jamais
quelque chose pour provoquer la consigne
était pas trop de sexe ou à peine pas
trop de provoc
pourtant cette fois encore rien à faire
deux collectifs pétitionnent depuis
trois mois à pourquoi pas l'art
contemporain à versailles mais à ce
moment-là à l'orangerie pourquoi
superposés encore une fois donc
et pourquoi me rendre la visite de
l'exposition durera camille obligatoire
le ressenti c'est un grand malaise parce
que c'est complètement déplacé
or le bon goût à la française excusez
moi c'est comme la cuisine c'est quand
les choses vont ensemble
attention mieux encore le collectif non
aux mangas envisage une action
judiciaire pour faire stopper
l'exposition qu'on me juge
c'est tout à fait normal je l'admets je
m'y attends même mais on essaie de
m'empêcher je trouve ça inadmissible
alors l'art contemporain at il sa place
au château du roi soleil
depuis deux ans les chiffres de
fréquentation des expos sont en hausse
et c'est tout le mal qu'on souhaite à
murakami